- [Gary] Well thanks for coming.
I would love to
answer any questions,
if you guys
wanna do as much Q&amp;A
and then maybe take a
couple selfies, hug it out.
(audience laughter)
And then I'll get
mentally prepared for my talk.
Anybody have any questions?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
As someone
transitioning straight out of
a lot of finance
and stuff like that,
coming into the tech world,
how much technical
expertise do you need
versus becoming
a jack of all trades
and learning bits and
bobs from where you can?
- [Gary] I think it's
predicated on the ambition
and the life cycle
of where you're at. Right?
The way I think about business
is actually the way
I think about parenting.
I don't expect a three year old
to have everything
figured out yet.
I think it depends
on the makeup of a team.
You look at a team like this
and everybody's gonna have
their strengths and weaknesses.
The one thing I do see a lot of,
because I'm a little bit more
of a hustler, entrepreneur.
I wasn't a developer.
I came up from selling
stuff and then a wine store
and so I get a lot of
hustlers and entrepreneurs
that come to me that
wanna be in the tech business
and they come up
with these ideas
and then they want a
dev shop to build it for them,
and they're gonna
launch this huge...
We're gonna be the next
Facebook because of this idea.
And then I go,
you're in the tech business
and you don't have
a tech cofounder.
I see that every day.
I think if the
ambition is very large
and it's tech-centric, you
need to have a tech cofounder
to really build an
actual big business.
I think if you're
building a fashion brand
and there's products
like Magento and Shopify
and WordPress
already in the marketplace
and your ambition is to build
a $10 million scarf business,
well then you don't need
to be the tech cofounder.
There's tools that can
get you there through Shopify
and maybe it's more
about the marketing skills,
or how do you
market the crayons?
I think you
have to go backwards.
I think the thing that
everybody makes mistakes with,
I think one of the best
things I've ever done...
I articulated about
my love of the journey
but I don't talk enough
about the way I strategize.
I kind of like playing the
role of charismatic crazy guy
but I definitely think
about stuff quite a bit.
And I think the best way to win
is to know where
the hell you're going.
And the reason I've been
pushing self-awareness
is not everybody
here is destined
to build a $500 million thing.
I also think it's crazy
that people don't realize
how amazing it is to
build a $1 million thing.
If you can build a $1 million
a year revenue business
and run on 30% net profit,
you have a crazy life.
And so we have this
whole world of everybody
trying to achieve for something
that's virtually impossible,
and they're putting
themselves in a position where,
by trying to build
something impossible,
they're gonna end
up working for a bank.
Because the one thing that
people haven't factored in yet
is, globally, the economy
has been pretty good
for the last decade,
or at least eight years.
My biggest concern is
the next economic slowdown.
Obviously, Ireland's had
different things going on
than the U.K., and
Brexit for the U.K. and the U.S.
Everybody has their
own microeconomic things
but I think the reality is,
globally right
now things are good.
People are tense about politics
but economic realities and
all the people that made money
in the 2000's or
have family money
are pouring money
into startup land.
A rugby startup can actually
get money from some individual
that made money prior.
The amount of $25,000
and $50,000 stupid checks
I've written in
the last five years.
When that goes away,
what happens?
And so I think that's a
long-winded answer
for a couple things.
One, you need to know
what your ambition is. Right?
Two, you have to figure
out if what you're doing now
is just the place
where you're transitioning
into the next
chapter of your career,
or is this the thing
that you wanna try to build.
If you actually decided
from a strategical standpoint
that the next two, three years
is really just about
learning, less posturing,
faking it to make it,
more just learning,
tasting it, understanding the
grass is not always greener.
Yeah startup land is
better than finance land
'cause people aren't as
douchey or this and that,
but there's a lot of
things that aren't as good.
Like pressure,
like it's all on you.
Like duh-duh-duh-duh-duh.
Well then if you've
made the macro decision
that this is a stepping stone
and this is how you're
gonna go about the world,
all of a sudden you're
not spending most of your time
trying to make the
most money out of this,
you're taking it in a
totally different mindset.
You've almost got a
university-like mentality
to the execution.
You don't wanna
go out of business,
you don't wanna have
to go back to get a job.
But I'm giving advice
to everybody right now.
You really have to know what
you're doing, at the macro.
And the other thing is
you have to be flexible enough
to know it changes.
What your ambition
is at 19 and 15 and 22
is different than what
your ambition is at 41.
You have to be
flexible in that reality.
I think it's a strategic answer.
I think you need to
think about tasting everything
because you're a young man
and you wanna figure
out what the hell you like
and what you're good at.
There's this
incredible access point
of what you're great
at and what you love.
When you stumble into
being somebody like me,
you really win when what
you're naturally great at
is what you naturally
love the most, and away you go.
The amount of people
that I meet every day
that are great at something
but have no interest
in being a CFO.
They're insane with numbers
but they don't wanna do it.
They wanna sing. Right?
And so that's tough.
You see it in athletics.
People don't
understand athletes.
The amount of
athletes that just do it
because it was the
best way, in the same way
that somebody goes
and becomes an accountant,
and they don't love competition,
and they don't love the sport.
It's crazy when you look at them
'cause you're like,
you're one of the 15 best,
and they don't
love it which is why
they're not the
greatest athlete of all-time.
The greatest
athletes of all-time
are the ones who
love it and have it.
And so I think what you need
to do is taste everything.
It's kind of like food.
You don't know what
your favorite food is
if you only eat one food.
So I would take
advantage of your youth
and your flexibility at this age
and try to taste everything,
play with everything,
figure out what
you might be good at,
what you might like, and
then you make a decision.
When I think
about being 41 years old
and feeling as young as I,
I feel like I'm 10 years old.
I feel like I have my
whole life in front of me.
And I think it's very difficult
for youngsters to realize that.
I'm sure some of us that have
lived a little bit longer...
How old are you?
- 26.
- When I was 26, 41 seemed
like a fucking long way away.
(group laughter)
My eight years older
cousin who worked with me
at Wine Library
seemed old to me.
He was 34 when I was 26.
So 41, fuck.
It's funny for me to think
about how you're seeing me,
but I'm telling you,
you're gonna feel
exactly the way you
feel right now at 41.
And so that's interesting,
because when
people understand that,
you can start
deploying more patience.
Because right now
you wanna prove it, right?
Yeah. Quickly.
I can read that because
first words out of your mouth
always are such an indicator
of what's on your mind.
I never cared to
fake it 'til I made it
because I didn't
care what people thought.
When you can eliminate that,
shit changes real quick.
Even think about high school
and then going into college.
High school is
so tough for people
because it's the apex of when
everything is about
what other people think.
And then you love the
transition to university
or the last year of high school
cause you care a little less.
Those first couple
years of high school,
I don't know the school system
exactly how you guys do it here
but everybody's wrapped up
in that 12 to 17-year-old age
of everything is about
what everybody else thinks
and that's why so
many people hate that era.
I just never went
through that luckily,
just hardwiring,
good parenting,
serendipity,
circumstance,
wrapping my self esteem in
things that I was great at.
I'm not really good at
thinking about what I'm bad at.
Even in interviews,
the only time I get stumped
is they're like,
"What do you struggle with,"
or, "What's a failure?"
I'm like uh, I just
don't even like, quantify it.
I don't think it's worth it.
I think people dwell too much.
- So what is the best
collaboration that either you've
had as one of your businesses,
or that you've seen happen
in startups?
- I give away
all my best advice.
DailyVee I'm showing inside
meetings to what the strategy
of my company is, and my
competitors can just watch it
and copy, I mean it's
crazy what I'm actually doing,
'cause it speaks to my
confidence that I'm always gonna
keep inventing the next
thing and my understanding
that 99% of people
aren't gonna do anything
about it anyway.
So I just bought PureWow,
which is a women's media
publishing company, it's
like a Refinery29 competitor.
I saw the Refinery29 CEO at
CES, and I rolled up on him,
and we've been friends for
a long time, acquaintances,
friendly, and he had a
good vibe, but I addressed
it immediately, I'm
like listen, you know I want
to rip your head off, like
I'm competitive, it's a game,
like that's what I do.
I'm like, but then
I said to him, but honestly,
I think we should join up
and we should go after
Conde Nast and Hearst
and there's much bigger media
women companies than us,
together we can really do some
damage, and I don't care if
I get 50 cents or 30 cents
on the dollar, I think the
best collaborations are the
most unlikely.
When Burger King
asked McDonald's,
on that campaign
they did, I don't know
if you guys saw this, where
they asked to make a love child
of the Big Mac and the Whopper.
To me, there's, if
tomorrow Nike and Adidas,
in the height of Yeezy's
going after the Nike brand,
did a collaboration,
to me, you even said it,
the most unlikely ones.
It's easy when a Crayon
company does a JV with like
a sock company and they
make a co-pack like,
they're not really competing.
I think the most interesting
ones are when you have
real genuine competition,
and people collaborate,
and so I think the ones that
are most interesting is when
Facebook and Snapchat will
have secret meetings and say
you know what, we have to
team up on vertical video,
because that's bigger than
what we're competing against
each other, 'cause we have
to take down television ads.
That's interest, you
know, I love that stuff.
I know that's pretty
frothy, but I think that's
when it gets most interesting.
So FedEx and UPS should
get together and say listen,
Amazon and Uber are dangerous.
What can we do together?
- [Woman] So
disrupt the disruptors.
Disrupt the disruptors and
it's most interesting to me
when the incumbents that
are on the verge of being
disrupted are
smart enough to disrupt.
So like for example,
every hotel company in the world
should have gotten together,
threw money together,
and then bought residential,
and then created an
Airbnb competitor,
you know what I mean?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- That to me is really neat.
Now I know that's pretty heady.
On a more small business level,
I think it gets really
interesting when the next
generation comes in, and
they yell at their father
that not everything
is competition,
and you can do business
with the guy down the street.
My best collaborations
was when I had no money.
When Wine Library had no
money, none, we were doing
$3.8 million a year,
10% gross profit,
before expenses,
we had no money,
there was no marketing budget.
My first year's marketing
budget was $14,000.
What did I do?
I went to a lot of the other
local businesses in Millburn,
and asked them if I could
put a bottle of wine
on their counter at the
barbershop with little coupons.
- [Woman] So why do you
think holds people back?
I mean, your GaryVee, okay.
- Yes.
- [Woman] And you've
always had that,--
- Yes.
- [Woman] I'm just gonna fix...
What do you think
holds people back from those...
- Human inefficiencies.
Fear, ego, I don't need you.
I can do it.
Cynicism, I don't trust you.
You're not gonna lead,
when I leave, you're gonna
just take the flyers,
throw 'em in the garbage,
and drink my wine.
- [Woman] Right.
- That's what hold my dad back.
Cynicism.
- [Woman] Okay.
You know?
Yeah, cynicism.
- My first question is, you
talk a lot about young people,
not having patience.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What do you think
are the other major factors
that young people
don't really have today?
That hold people back.
- Experience.
I think young kids are
getting tricked right now,
and think just because
it's a technology boom,
and just because they
understand it, that they have
this great advantage over
45-year-old executors.
It's audacity, which I love.
Channeled properly, it
gives them the lack of fear
to do things, so I really
don't talk a lot about it,
'cause I don't wanna stop it,
'cause I think it's their
greatest gift as well.
But I think it's patience,
I think it's lack of experience,
and then biggest
one is lack of talent.
Every young kid
thinks they're entitled
to be an entrepreneur now.
It's the cool thing.
Truth is it's not gonna
work out, like it just isn't.
The math doesn't work out,
like 98 percent of the people
that are starting
startups are gonna lose.
And again, the reason
I started with the economic,
like the economic growth of
the globe, is keeping a fake
entrepreneur alive.
Most of your friends, in their
20's that have businesses,
aren't actually making
money if they're in tech.
They've raised
capital and they're
losing money every month.
That's ultimately something
that doesn't work out.
- [Man] Second question
sorry, a lot of the time
I do web design development
for small businesses.
A lot of the time I can go in,
I can show a portfolio,
I can say I want to
expand that portfolio,
and they still might
choose paying like 5,000 euro,
ridiculous amounts
of money when I can say
I can do the same work,
here's the work that I've done.
Is there any way
of combating that?
- No.
- [Man] No?
- You're being subjected
to age discrimination.
So the way to combat
it is to not dwell on it,
and not try to sell
people who aren't sellable.
It's a volume game,
just go to every business,
instead of focusing on trying
to convince the dog shop
owner that he's
making a mistake.
Though one of the great
things I've always done,
'cause I started off as
a young kid, and nobody,
I mean, I started off as,
they would walk into my
family business, and
I'm like can I help you with
wine they're like, you
can't help me with wine.
For the first seven
years they were right.
I was 15 years old,
but I knew a lot more,
and if they gave me data
I could tell them what they
should drink, but I think
that one thing I learned
very early on by all that
rejection, both being a bad
student, and both being a
kid that tried to sell wine
when he was underage and
nobody would listen to him,
is that you can't sell
people that aren't sellable.
You're way better off putting
you energy and crushing it
for the people that give
you an at-bat, right?
Versus the people that aren't.
- What does it take for
you to invest in a company?
And then two, I'm,
preschools, it's a niche market,
I have a masters in preschool
education, I have a degree,
but I still feel, I've talked
to over 1,000 preschool
providers, done service
with them, I'm talking to
them everyday, but I'm
still not sure how to market
the product to them, just
'cause it's small and yeah.
So what would be
your advice on marketing?
- As far as investing, you've
kind of heard my themes.
I have not been
investing much at all.
I'm about to do this new Apple
show, where I'm one of the
mentors, and I think
it's gonna put me in the light
of investing a lot again so,
I have to figure out what
my strategy is,
'cause I'm gonna have a great
amount of deal flow,
but I do think we're in an
over-saturated, overvalued
market, so I've been doing
almost no investing.
If I was to invest now,
it's only betting on the jockey,
and they've had to
be successful before.
Like, now listen,
Mark Zuckerberg
was not successful before,
Evan Spiegel was
not successful before.
I'm gonna leave money on the
table in an incredible way
by having that strategy.
I just need to go
through this cycle.
I don't like it right now
and so I'd rather invest
in somebody who's done
it before and is on their
second or third, 'cause
it gives me data that they've
been able to navigate
actually building a business
versus building a machine
that's built for fundraising.
'Cause that's the majority of
what's being built right now.
- [Woman 2] And,
like it's preschools,
they're not really business
people, they're not enterprise.
So I just feel like,
should I go out to them and talk
to them one-on-one,
should it be digital?
- No you should go talk
to them one-on-one.
The best thing to do
ever is to go one-on-one,
and reverse engineer
what made you get the first
10 people to buy it, and
then make that your strategy.
I'm a very big fan of that.
Like, instead of guessing
what it's gonna be,
go and sell it, see
what the common theme was
that made people buy it,
and then scale that
in your communications.
Digital is not a,
it's not a tactic.
Digital is where
people's attention is.
So what you put into
the digital is what matters.
Just having a
Facebook strategy right?
It's what you say.
Like the creative is
still the variable of success.
It's what you say.
- [Man 2] So really depending on
our community and our followers
to which we had attract
funds, volunteers will join
us on the project,
doing one in Kenya.
It was quite a, say
six months we get to,
work around 1,000
followers, different...
What kind of tips or
strategies do you have to get to
the next, let's say 10,000?
- So first of all,
you shouldn't worry
about things like that.
Like in general, just even
worrying about those proxies,
like to me, I assume you're
talking about 1,000 followers
across Facebook,
Twitter, things like that?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Is that what you mean?
So first of all, I think
the bigger question
is what does that mean?
So for example,
you know what I mean?
- [Man 2] Quality...
- Of course, it's
depth versus width.
So if you're only KPI was 10,000
followers, we could create
a word-of-mouth distribution
strategy that could, right?
Like click this, it
auto populates all this,
you gamify why
people follow you.
I mean you can
give away an iWatch
and pick up 500 followers right?
So I think that you need to
think about it differently.
So for example, if the
head of the United Nations
was one of your followers
and wanted to always talk
about what you're doing,
that's far more interesting
to me than having
48,000 random people following
you on Instagram.
I think that's the real answer.
The way to get to the best
version of that real answer
is content.
And so what I would
do if I were you guys,
is I would shift into
the mindset of thinking
that you're a media
company, comma, NGO.
And what that would do, and
I actually think that's the
advice I'd give all of you.
So I think you should
blog everyday about the world
of preschool in
Ireland, like everything.
Profile a teacher, speak
about something that happened
50 years ago, a media company.
If you all think of
yourself as a media company,
media, content is the
gateway to the business.
Look what I do.
I Gary, am a media
company, it's the gateway
to building the fastest,
biggest-growing agency
in the history of advertising.
I always say to people,
if they really pay attention
to what I'm doing,
they'll get much more value
out of me than anything else.
Like why am I
making so much video?
Why am I documenting everything?
Why am I producing a t-shirt?
Why am I doing the Apple show?
Why am I doing what I'm doing?
No matter, I'll never be,
as great of a communicator
as I am, right?
And I'm really good at it,
that's why I've been successful.
I'll never be able to
fully synthesize ahead of
my own actions.
So what does that mean?
That means you should write a
Medium blog post every week.
It means that you
should do a podcast
in the NGO space every week.
Why did Scott Harrison
and Adam Braun from Pop
and, excuse me, Pencil of
Promise and Charity: Water
become such players?
Because they were,
they were club promoters,
they were marketers,
they treated it differently.
And the truth is, too
many people in the NGO space
take for granted
people's goodwill.
They think just 'cause
they're an NGO, people should
give a shit.
There's a drillion NGO's.
There's a drillion
things that are trying
to do good for the world.
So content, podcast, video,
written, quotes, pictures,
and then tactics.
Fifteen hashtags when you
post your picture on Instagram
three times a day.
- [Man 2] Now we speak
with a lot of individuals
who want to join our cause and
they want to join our projects.
But we also speak
to a lot of companies.
And we talk about
corporate social responsibility.
- Of course.
- [Man 2] I'm curious in
your scene if you ever
come across these
kind of subjects and
what's interesting for them?
So what we could
offer companies in terms of--
- The first thing you
have to do is realize
they're full of shit.
(group laughter)
They just are.
Like, yeah.
It's, companies
do for a purpose,
99.7% of time
for commerce interests.
They think it looks good
to the person they're trying
to sell soap to.
And so the second you
take the romance out of it,
and say okay great,
this company is
very excited about us,
they're not excited about you.
They're excited
about using you as a proxy
to make themselves look like,
the reason I never talk
about my non-profit work,
which is substantial,
financially and time-committed,
is 'cause I am
disgusted by my fancy friends
that use it to paint
the picture that they're
a good human being.
I love that some people think
that I'm too self-promotional.
I'm comfortable
promoting about my vanity,
I'm not comfortable
in promoting my heart.
I think that you just do that.
So it's the reverse, you know
I love when people razz me,
and fall for tricks of
what other people are doing.
It's just very basic thinking.
I think when you
take the romance out,
you've got a much better
chance of being successful
with those companies.
If you walk in there, and
realize okay, this is business,
and what they really
care about is their brand
being associated with
something that's good,
which then leads to more
selling stuff, you strategies
start changing on
what you say you're willing
to do with them, you
start getting more of them
to do things
that you want to do.
You always have to
know what the real game is.
- [Woman 3] A lot of the time,
I'm a single mom with very
little extra family support.
- Yes.
- [Woman 3] It's
crazy a lot of the time.
- It's hard.
- [Woman 3] It's really--
- It's hard, it's really hard.
- [Woman 3] And when I find that,
although it all
starts to go slow,
and the patience there.
- You're gonna be slower,
you're gonna be slower.
- [Woman 3] And how
do I communicate that?
Because that is--
- Communicate to who?
The world?
- [Woman 3] No,
let's say, I'm from Galway
a smaller area, I don't know.
You're almost
doing very personal
with the people who
are kind of the key holders
or the gatekeepers of that
city, with entrepreneurship.
- Okay, well, what
do you need from them?
- [Woman 3] I need to
get into an accelerator
to get into that structure early,
to get like, let's say
there's one, let's just say
there's 15,000.
15,000 would
absolutely change my life.
- I think, I think
- [Woman 3] Like it's ridiculous.
- I think you have to
go to the decision maker
in that accelerator--
- [Woman 3] Yeah.
- tell the truth of your world,
and realize that 99%
of decision makers
in that situation
aren't gonna give a
shit about your product.
- [Woman 3] Well this
is what I kind of thoguht
but it actually came
to me, I had one of these
come back to me.
While I was in a meeting,
discussing and
getting financial backing--
- Yeah.
- [Woman 3] to
satisfy their (inaudible),
- Yeah.
- [Woman 3] We can help
you there. And then
this guy walked up
and he actually felt a bit,
I felt like he was threatened,
like he's in his
sixties or something
and he was like,
"Oh, you, I remember from six
months ago you applied.
"You're a single
mom, aren't you?"
And he was not--
- Keep going.
- [Woman 3] And I was like,
how old is he now, ten, eleven?
And I honestly
felt like he was, like,
blocking me.
It was so bizarre
and I moved on with it
and you wouldn't
have noticed that,
if I was there I
would've been like,
"Yeah, oh my God, he's great.
"And anyways, da-da-da-da."
But--
- Inside--
- [Woman 3] Inside, it's like--
- He's just one of the 99.
You just gotta
(Woman 3 laughs)
You just gotta find the one.
- [Woman 3] And these are like--
- And by the way,
and by the way,
I do want to say something,
because people
don't think about this.
'Cause I just went through this
with this new Apple show.
He's got a
fiscal responsibility.
These accelerators
were given money by people.
Like, like, you know like...
The raw game of business
is very unforgiving.
I don't think these VCs,
I razz them all the time,
'cause I wanna
remind entrepreneurs
that their model
is the following.
They're gonna
give you all bad advice
except for the
one that gets through
and pays for everything.
They're gonna push all
your companies too hard,
and not patience,
because their
model is predicated on
getting one to break through
and pay for the whole fund.
So they push everybody
to be a huge exit,
most fail,
one gets through, they win.
But the truth is,
somebody gave them money.
When I write a check as an LP,
a limited partner,
and I write a
$500,000 check,
I'm trusting that individual
to return my money,
and with profit.
And I could put it
in the stock market,
I could buy real estate,
I can, this is my family.
I earned my money.
So, they have a responsibility.
So, now, I think there is grace
and I think there's ways
to be a polite human being,--
- [Woman] Ireland's
a funny place.
- Yeah, but honestly,
the world's a
funny place, right?
Like, I think the
reason I over-index
is I've found some
sort of balance, I'm me.
I'm massively aggressive
and a good dude,
and people are able to get real,
I'm giving you an answer that
most people aren't giving
which is, I'm not
so sold they're wrong.
But I do believe that
somebody would be like,
hey, listen, I'm not worried
that this may take 13 years,
or four or seven or nine.
The problem is,
they're impatient.
Everybody's impatient.
This is not just
a young kid thing,
the world is impatient.
So, I think, again,
I think it's a
similar answer I've given
a couple times now.
Let me give you a
great macro piece of advice:
Eliminate emotion.
Be empathetic.
You know what your headache is,
like, hey, fuck you, asshole,
I'm a single mom
and I'm doing it right,
and I've got things to do, but
be empathetic to him.
I look at him and say,
he might really need this exit.
Like, who the hell knows
what happened in his life.
Maybe he needs this
investment period of his life,
everybody just assumes that
because they're an accelerator,
most of the people that I know
that run accelerators
have no money.
Like, this is the thing that
needs to make them money.
They worked 15 years
to build a reputation,
to be able to get
people that had money
to give them money,
and this is the
moment, this is it.
- [Woman 3] Yeah.
So, you know,
when you go to that,
it's why I never
get mad about anything.
Right?
I mean, you see DRock reacting,
it's why I don't get
mad if somebody says,
"You're a con artist."
I'm like, okay.
You've watched four
seconds of one video
where I was peacocking
and being my
egotistical, cocky self,
and that's what you think,
and I get it, fine.
Like, I don't expect you to,
you know, people come up
to me at events like this,
I'm like, I'm sorry,
I don't know who you are.
All these people, I'm like,
you don't need to be sorry.
9% of the
world doesn't know.
Like, to me, I think
empathy is lacking in our world.
I think the political climate
in all of our countries
and Europe and the
U.S. is lacking empathy.
We're going this way,
instead of this way,
and there's no, neither
side is right about that.
So we lack empathy.
Empathy has
been my calling card.
- [Woman 3] What I have done
when I started to take in media,
and opened up a thrift shop
based on following you. (laughs)
- The thrift shop is so awesome!
I'm, I really
think that selling,
like, buying
something and selling it,
the reason I'm
more excited about it
than people realize,
is I think I'm
teaching a lot of people
a true survival skill.
Like, when you act like,
the amount of people
that are actually going
to have a successful startup,
because on the side,
they were going to bookstores,
buying and selling,
and when shit hits the fan
they'll have a
little money to stay alive
just long enough to get out
to the other side and win,
I'm so proud,
this may be,
it's such a funny thing.
It seems so weird like
a lot of my tech friends
are like, "What are you doing?"
But I'm really excited about it,
because I think a lot
of you are gonna learn
how to sell.
- [Man 3] We're doing the 20k.
- You are.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- It's cool, right?
- [Man 3] (laughs)
Yeah, it's cool.
- It's just like,
and the other thing is, like,
a lot of people need money.
Like, having extra
money really impacts
97% of people,
so no matter where you
are on the economic scale
selling random stuff in your
house that you're not using
and having an
extra thousand euros
at the end of the
year is better than not,
and you learn something.
It's a real win-win,
it's a real win-win.
It's been really fun,
it's been really fun to watch.
(hip hop music)